a tuesday pft ot pft pm extra pft be on
pft live
we're still enjoying the new format
without the radio clock that requires us
to take breaks all the time we can get
into deeper conversations in this
setting we have no breaks to worry about
at all we can talk as long as we want
and let's start with a topic chris that
has kind of come up a couple of times
this offseason as it relates to derek
henry and the titans derek henry has
signed his franchise tender um and we
don't know whether or not that's going
to become a long-term deal christian
mccarrifer we talked about on the show
today
wants a long-term contract and i believe
will draw a line in the sand to try to
get it the question is when we look at
some of the contracts that have been
meted out to
running backs in recent years why is
anyone
paying big money for running backs
because have any of them actually earned
the second contracts they've received
no well no i think it's a really good
conversation it's scary i'd be scared to
give a running back big money on that
second contract right now no doubt about
it i mean when you just look at the last
three guys to get big money
you know i'm scarred by that of course
ezekiel elliott last year yeah i don't
think he performed uh up to that capa or
his capabilities are up to the standard
of being the number one running back in
the sport of course we've seen what
happened with todd gurley and the risk
reward factor there
le'veon bell another guy in the mix
there david johnson i mean you you know
those the last four big running back
contracts have all not really worked out
in the favor of the team so to me that's
the big thing mike like christian
mccaffrey who with every other position
you would go okay
he's the next guy up and he's towards
the top of his position if not at the
top
you know we expect them always to be the
highest paid guy right in any other
position but a running back i want to
sit there and go i don't know if that's
necessarily a true fact of the matter
here i don't know can is carolina going
to throw 16 million dollars a year out
to christian mccaffrey i think it's very
debatable to me
well you could argue krista mccaffrey's
in a different position than some of
these other running backs because of
what he means both in the passing game
in the running game only the third guy
in league history to have over a
thousand yards in a season both rushing
and receiving but still it's a position
where we see the wear and tear very
quickly accumulate we see guys who by
the time they are earning the big money
by the time they are a couple of years
into that second contract or in some
cases the first year into that second
contract their best days are fading into
the rearview mirror it is a buyer beware
proposition
and the rams
surely regretted giving todd gurley the
contract the jets surely regretted
paying le'veon bell once it became a
free agent and the cowboys may regret
giving ezekiel elliot what they gave him
especially as they're struggling to get
dak prescott signed
you just have to wonder will the
panthers do it will the titans do it
from the titans perspective maybe it's
better to have derek henry continuing to
chase the carrot and let someone else
give him big money let someone else step
into that situation where they may say
why in the hell did we do this i just
feel like with so many of these running
backs except adrian peterson who got his
second contract in 2011 and was the
nfl's mvp the following year after
recovering from a torn acl which you
know at first it looked like they made a
mistake paying him all that money
because of the torn acl
in recent years the contracts that have
been given to running backs the big
contracts most of them have been
mistakes and most of them should result
in teams saying we shouldn't have done
it and it really makes me wonder is that
going to keep the titans from doing it
with henry and will keep the panthers
from doing it with mccaffrey and will
they ultimately have to trade him his
benefit right now chris is he's the face
of the franchise post cam newton post
luke lee they can't afford to move on
from him if they want to put fans in the
stands although that may not matter this
year because there may be no fans
allowed at the games anyway
well and you know to further your point
there at the end which i think is very
real i mean yes you're right he's the
face of the franchise right now and then
it's matt rule and joe brady and again
we've talked about this a lot but joe
brady
is running that sean payton scheme in
new orleans the back out of the
backfield in the pass game
is going to be paramount to the success
for teddy bridgewater and the panthers
offense so he does have a little bit of
a stranglehold there altogether but i
really think with like these nfl teams
yeah they're gonna have to start
figuring out
creative ways to save their butts on the
back end uh with some of these running
backs because yeah you mentioned it
adrian peterson's you know a diamond in
the haystack it doesn't happen very
often he's a freaking nature he's one of
the three greatest running backs of all
time for my money you know we saw
lashawn mccoy okay i would say another
guy who got you know big money before it
became really big but at least he stayed
healthy and played to that level but
those are rare hall of fame talent type
guys and uh yeah so the running back
position it falls in a hurry you know i
i you know you it just does these guys
four or five years of getting car crash
after car crash all of a sudden you get
to year six and you go whoa he lost a
step and i saw it with running backs in
my nfl career it can fall off a cliff in
a real real hurry and that's what i
would worry about
all right uh i think we've resolved that
topic we can move on to some of the
questions posed by you at the pft
twitter account let's start with a
question from
jason moore otherwise known as at
laneman24 is it more likely that the
lack of draft prep hurts incompetent
organizations more or gives a bigger leg
up to the well run teams chris what do
you think
well it's a good this is a good question
very good question i actually think it
hurts the well-run teams i do i think
the well-run teams have this process
down
to a science to where
yes between the evaluation of film
personal workouts and meeting with a guy
they know what they really like and i
think the the aspect of the personal
workout
is where i think it's going to really
hurt the well-run teams the well-run
teams are able to go oh i saw something
on film i like all right you know i'm
not so sure about the competition around
him and all those things man you know i
also like these other guys at this
position too let's get them in here for
a personal workout and then we can get a
little closer look and i think the
really well-run teams have an eye for
you know certain positions or certain
players or just knowing what to look for
in a workout to go
that's going to translate to the nfl
right i always think of dante scarneckia
here mike with this donte scarnecchia
had like his own routine in new england
that he put the offensive lineman
through
when it was a free agent or a draft guy
which was not the same as any other
offensive line coach i ever saw put
through a routine and it was certain
stretch flexibility drills other
strength drills all these type of things
that allowed dante scarneckia to nitpick
a guy and go oh i like that he can do
this and he can do that and he can't do
this and then skarnekia could find that
diamond in the rough or whoever it may
be or distinguish who was better and not
better and you're going to lose that
aspect if you have that guy that with a
keen eye in your organization right now
remember they did have scar neckia go
with them to the scouting combine so the
patriots got a little bit of that but
not the extent that they're used to and
i agree with you look even though the
good teams the best teams will come up
with creative ways to thrive or survive
in this environment for the teams that
were dysfunctional anyway who cares
we're throwing a dart as it is right
we're taking the guys who slide down the
board because we don't know who the hell
house to take anyway so i i agree with
you the more you take away the
opportunity for teams to get maximum
information the teams that know how to
gather it and make the most of it are
going to have less information less
valuable information than they usually
have whereas the teams that that don't
know what the hell they're doing
who cares if you don't have the ability
to go do all these things they're not
spending the money and the time and then
all the expertise to do it right anyway
well yeah exactly you know and even
another aspect of it is you know hey
let's let's take for example like pete
carroll and john schneider i look at
those two guys and go man they have
unbelievable people skills they know how
to work you know guys who maybe had a
little bit of a checkered past or not
the best like history on the personal
side and they can work them into the
organization it just seems like it works
good you know they have an unbelievable
skill set of communication and and
people skills to where that's gonna get
lost in this process too i know you can
do the zoom and facetime cause
but you know
do the seattle seahawks take dk metcalf
last year with there's some of the bad
rumors that were going around on him
you know without the fact that they got
to meet him and be around him and really
get to know him and spend a day i'm just
giving examples of like that where yeah
i know zoom zoom is good but you're not
really getting to spend the day eat
dinner really get into some different
topics everything like that see the body
language of a guy see if he's moody or
not anything like that you know the
teams that have really good people
skills i think they're hurt in this
whole conversation too
yeah you know i agree with you my first
thought was the the good teams are still
going to do a great job in the draft but
i think it is a greater challenge for
them because what made them great at
drafting was taking full advantage of
all the things that you can
do to prepare to gather information to
work directly with players etc all right
next up gears of ted
will covet impact the salary cap going
forward and chris i'll take this one
first i don't see how it won't because
the salary cap is driven by the money
that was generated in the prior year the
nfl is going to take a hit this year in
its total revenue there's no way around
it if you can't have fans at games
that's less money that comes into the
coffers and i think the only chance they
have
at
keeping this
this uh revenue stream big enough so it
doesn't affect next year's salary cap is
if
there's no college football there's no
high school football
and the nfl expands yeah to
three windows on saturday friday night
and and ultimately has nine broadcast
windows per week instead of the usual
five thursday three on sunday and monday
at friday and three on saturday gives
you nine in all if they do that and then
come out of it kind of on the fly with
with bigger broadcast deals now good
luck finding
networks they're going to cough up that
kind of money be able to cough up that
kind of money but i think that's the way
to potentially do it because look people
are going to be looking for programming
if there's no college football people
are going to want things to watch on
saturday
and people are going to want to put
things on tv for people to watch when
there is no college football if it comes
to that and i really do believe right
now and nobody knows but if i had to
guess right now i'd say there won't be
high school football there won't be
college football there will be nfl
football in the fall they'll find a way
to play and maybe they'll find a way to
play on fridays and saturdays to make
back the money that comes from not
having fans in the stands either way
either way though it's a real dynamic
for 2021
less money made this year by the nfl is
less money available to share with the
players next year
yep and excuse the noise in the
background my dog bentley he's got his
bone here and he's going to town on it
all right so if you're hearing that
that's what that is but back to the
facts of the matter here you're right i
mean yes it's definitely going to impact
the salary cap i would think so you know
i thought about that too right off the
bat but the other aspect yeah the thing
that came off to my mind was you know
you hit on it you know i as it looks
right now it's certainly going to be a
whole lot harder to have a college
football season with as many teams as
there are in the school aspect and all
of those things you know the nfl i think
it'll be easier for them to pull it off
not easy but you know if they can pull
it off and there is no high school
football or college football oh my gosh
and you know if there's no sports at all
up until that point i mean people are
going to be like drew like you know
drooling for football or sports or
competition or any sense of live tv and
i would think the ratings would have a
chance to just go absolutely through the
roofs as people are starved for the
content and the action but also probably
still
unwilling to go about their social lives
and you know hey yeah i envisioned in
september and october that i'm probably
still going to be thinking like
do i
go out to dinner with my wife on friday
night date night tonight i i don't know
you know how dangerous would the culvert
19 implications still be so
uh you know that's that's where my mind
is with that
you hear my dog in the background can
you hear him i i i i hear him i hear him
i think that bentley is very impatient
you were explaining before we got
started bentley is accustomed to after
the show ends going outside and playing
fetch bentley is very anxious to get
outside and play fetch all right yeah
we'll wrap this up so bentley can get
his fetch in no screw bentley don't
worry he's a dog he'll be fine don't
worry bentley bentley really looks like
a good boy i think even though i'm not a
big fan of german shepherds because when
i used to deliver newspapers there was
one specific german shepherd that even
though it was chained up it scared the
crap out of me every day that it's not
that traditional
black and brown menacing german shepherd
look bentley's got the all black where
you don't realize he's a german shepherd
so i that that i i like bentley's a
good-looking dog i like bentley i would
like battling until until bentley tries
to chase me all right and briggs 401 how
likely do you think it is that shawn
watson ends up in new england after this
season remember chris there were some
odds that were published a week or two
ago and they were one of the offshore
sites and we stay away from naming those
because they're technically illegal and
there's legalized gambling now in the
nfl i haven't seen an uh a legitimate
sports book with these odds but the idea
that watson was the favorite at like
plus 300 to be the patriots quarterback
week one of next season you know on the
surface it's like is this ridiculous yes
but
it does feel like he's a little upset
that deandre hopkins is gone and you
just wonder whether he gets to the point
where he's had enough of bill o'brien
and he makes a power play to get out of
houston and uh if he would want to go
anywhere else why wouldn't he want to go
to new england well i mean yeah i hear
that now you listen again we know new
england right now seems to be all in
with jared stidham and they want to see
where that goes uh do desean watson do i
think he would fit the new england way
and fit up there yes and of course he's
had a little bit of a precursor with
that with bill o'brien because he tries
to run things that way as well
but i think ultimately
you know again this is where houston
they got to gauge how the season goes
next year a little bit they got to be
aware of what's going on in new england
i would be scared of anybody stealing
deshaun watson and that we've upset him
to where yes you might have to get
through the halfway through the year
next year and go oh wait new england's
not playing well stidham's not the guy
the future
and i would be scared as hell that they
steal deshaun watson or anything like
that you know i would think that the
sean watson new contract needs to come
now you don't let a desean watson ever
hit free agency just like patrick
mahomes this is a once in a generation
type talent he is a superstar and you
are going to be in the playoff
conversation for the next 10 years
because this guy can make it happen no
matter who's around him and you just
don't let this guy walk out the door
and look here's the other thing to
realize because people assume that given
the structure of the nfl
if you want to keep a player against his
wishes you can keep that player
indefinitely here's how it works for a
player like desean watson first round
pick you have the fifth year option so
you can at a minimum keep him for five
years you can tag him once
tag him twice at a twenty percent
increase over the first year tag the
third time it's a forty four percent
increase it becomes ridiculously
expensive especially if you use the
exclusive tag like the cowboys did with
dak prescott if a player is determined
to get out of a given city he has to put
in at most seven years before he can
walk if you're not a first round pick
you can get out in six years like kirk
cousins did in washington but if if
desean watson wants out of houston he
can get out and here's the other thing
too you don't even have to put in the
full seven years what if all of a sudden
you say to the team i just don't want to
be here anymore and i'll do the bare
minimum i'll do what's required of me
contractually i'll show up for the
mandatory minicamp i'll show up for
training camp but i'm not doing anything
else i'm not coming to any of the otas
i'm not going to be involved in the
off-season program i'm not going to stay
early or show up early and stay late i'm
not going to work on my off day don't
bother calling me up and talking to me
about the game plan
i'm just an employee like everyone else
on the team i'm not going to be a quasi
member of management because i don't
want to be here anymore i don't know how
you can be effective as a modern day nfl
team without a quarterback who isn't all
in we haven't seen that play out yet
but but i think if a team senses that
the relationship is moving in that
direction that's the time to get value
for him because one of these days one of
these quarterbacks is going to say i
just work here i'm i'm not here to do
anything more than what you're paying me
to do and i'm not going to be this
member of management who sets the
example for the rest of my teammates
yeah well that's dangerous you're right
and the organization is not going to go
on the upward trend if the quarterback
is that way so that it's a very real
aspect you're bringing up now if it did
come to that that's when the houston
texans need to go okay that's fine but
this can't get released to the public if
we hear one inkling and pub and the
public you know
the media anything like that
then we hear one inkling that oh you're
not happy here deshaun watson doesn't
really want to play here and now it
hurts our trade value as an organization
but we don't care we'll ruin your career
i mean that's what teams would have to
do in that instance pretty much because
again what happens more times than not
with these type of players when we know
there's a disgruntled player and he's
not going to play it ends up hurting the
organization because they lose their
trade value because everyone goes well
he's not going to play for you anyways
he's not going to be there so don't you
want to get something for him and then
that other team that's a part of it has
a leg up in the trade conversation so
that's where it gets dicey for the
organizations and
if it does come to that which i don't
expect it to uh
they got to be able to protect
themselves that way too
look at what they did with deandre
hopkins they moved on from him before
the storm arrived before it became
obvious he wanted that 22 million dollar
contract or thereabouts and would they
do that with deshaun watson so and yeah
we talked yesterday about whether or not
either side of the deandre hopkins david
johnson trade may be
hoping that there's a failed physical so
the trade falls apart from houston's
perspective you just wonder if desean
watson has said enough things behind the
scenes that would maybe make the texans
think twice about deandre hopkins
leaving and think twice about paying
de'andre hopkins what he wants but i
don't think it's come to that i don't
think either side wants that deal to
fall apart i don't think either side is
looking for a way to get out of that
deal but deshawn watson seemingly not
happy about deandre hopkins being gone
all right one more before we wrap mike
likes dirt has this question very
important question what have you learned
about yourself in quarantine something
philosophical a food preference anything
chris what have you learned about
yourself
all right two things that i've learned
about myself one i don't think i could
ever be a school teacher okay but just
uh the uh homeschooling and seeing what
you know my wife has been doing the the
majority of the meat and potatoes of
that but
just seeing that go down on a daily
basis i know that whoa
our teachers are doing a great job at a
great service for our country and that
is no easy task i'm just dealing with my
own kids i can't imagine dealing with 20
kids in a classroom so i have a whole
new
respect for them and the other thing is
i think i've just realized more of like
i guess i have ocd or i'm a little bit
of a creature of habit and me being
thrown out of my routine
i was really
almost as stressed by that mic as
anything until where i just feel like
i've just here recently finally got into
routine and calmed down but i would wake
up in the morning with like a pit in my
stomach about not sure how the day was
gonna unfold and it wasn't gonna be my
normal routine
yeah i mean i've learned two things
first is i i've learned how fortunate i
am that i already had this set up here
at my house because the transition for
me
was so
simple that i feel guilty about it i
know that millions out there
who haven't been touched by the virus
who have just been affected by this
dramatic change in reality they aren't
used to working at home
they can't actually work at home
they physically don't have the space
necessary to work at home they can't
stay out of the kitchen when they are at
home i've had 10 years to learn day in
and day out the discipline necessary to
not stray into a room that is literally
15 feet away from my office downstairs
so i was ready for this that this
this change for me hasn't really been a
change but especially the busy times of
the off season i don't go anywhere
anyway i'm home most of the time so i've
learned that you know what i mean of all
the blessings that i have i mean this
has been uh because it could have turned
me upside down it could have thrust my
life into disarray and i'm sensitive to
the fact that it has been a problem for
others and the one thing that i continue
to harp on whenever we have the
opportunity you know we talk all the
time about people being confined with
their families and doing things with
their families and maybe getting sick of
their families there's a lot of people
out there who are confined
alone
from somebody earlier today she's uh one
and a half miles away from her sister
and hasn't seen her in a month right and
and is alone there are so many people
who are going through this alone and i
think having others around having
animals around frankly helps you not go
as stir crazy as you would but for me
it's been an easy transition and i feel
grateful for that but i also feel guilty
for that and secondly one thing i've
learned is that
like the human animal
is a creature of routine a creature of
habit and for me as we continue to climb
this mountain
into this this
this fog that we have no idea where the
top of the mountain is
you just have to focus on
that each each movement
you know if you just stay focused on
where your foot's going to go next where
your hand is going to go next just one
day at a time one hour at a time have
little things you look forward to time
you spend with your family at night a tv
show that you watch every week a ritual
that you do we have pasta every sunday
night and we open a bottle of wine on
sunday night of course i open bottles of
wine the rest of the week but sunday
night it's got a special feel to it just
little things like that that you can
look forward to that get you through the
days you don't realize i mean it's
almost like your body is this machine
that can be hacked that can be
programmed and you just need to be
conscious of it and you need to make
sure you do these things and have these
things as part of your routine so just
keep you sane little things like that
keep you sane chris
yeah they do you're right we we have
we've done more family sit down dinners
enjoyed that you know tried to take the
positives you know i i do i'm trying to
look at this and go
man what am i going to think 20 years
from now about this whole thing yes this
is a weird time but i think in a lot of
ways i want to make sure that i'm very
appreciative that i've gotten to be
around my wife and two kids who were 9
and 13
and really got to enjoy them for
extended periods of time during very fun
parts of their life i mean 9 and 13 is
they're fun i mean as you can imagine
between social media video games the
crazy questions
them learning more about life
it is very enjoyable on a daily basis
and i certainly laugh and chuckle and i
just want to make sure yeah we're
stressed out but
i'm trying to do my best to to make sure
i keep it all in perspective to be uh
very
happy for what i have in life and and
really appreciate it
it really is amazing to think about how
we will look back on this time 5 10 15
20 years from now
and
will it be
ever normal again will it ever be the
way it was before now look maybe they
find a vaccine and maybe everybody's
fine and everybody gets it and everybody
who's either had coronavirus and
recovered from it you know they're
already fine or you get the vaccine and
you're fine but it just feels like it's
going to be a while before things are
back to normal it feels like it's going
to be a while before sports are back as
normal um and you know chris i'm
grateful that we've been able to keep
doing what we do i know that it helps
people out there who are looking for a
break from the bad news and i know it
helps me because for two and a half
three hours every morning
i can just focus on this
and i'm not watching the news and i'm
not sitting around worried about this
family member that family member you
know
our next grocery run and are we going to
be sure to properly wipe everything down
and just constantly being conscious of
washing your hands and not touching your
face and
that that background noise that and
that's really what it is it's a level of
background noise that has increased
dramatically things we have to worry
about and be conscious of and this every
day for me every weekday at least is a
couple of hours where i can forget about
that stuff and just focus on something
that feels normal of all the things that
have changed what we do
five days a week or for you four days a
week feels normal to me and really
that's the only thing in our lives
that in comparison to what was before
this all happened we can say is the
common thread that is normal
yeah no you're right it is and you know
i know i get a lot of positive feedback
from from friends and people i know that
are watching the show to go
you know hey this is it's fun it takes
my mind off it there's not a lot of
sports on tv or anything like that other
than reruns and this is live tv we're
talking about it and uh it is man i'm
very grateful for you as well and it's
really cool that hey this is the kind of
show we have anyways yes i'm not in the
studio but this is our normal format and
we haven't had to change it yeah i'm
sitting here in you know in my room we
call the cloud room because i have a
cloud couch behind me this big white
poofy thing you see
that's a little different but
nonetheless it feels the same and i
actually feel starting i'm starting to
feel very comfortable and in a routine
finally
and the best part about it is it has
been four weeks now since you have
busted my chops about moving to
connecticut that has become a non-issue
it has been a good four weeks i don't
have to worry about chris running the
boss saying hey florio should move up
here he should move up here that's not
an issue and uh uh i don't think it ever
will be uh after all of this all right
uh chris that's it for today you've got
uh uh chris sims on button coming up
later today what do you got we're gonna
shoot that later today gonna do our top
uh my top five edge rushers in this nfl
draft a good group of guys gonna narrow
that down down to my top five me paul
burmeister hit on a few other news
topics but really going to be doing
draft stuff from here on out with the
chris sins unbutton podcast
all right well we'll check that out
later today we'll be back tomorrow with
another edition of pft live everyone
stay safe stay smart we appreciate your
time we appreciate you carving out some
of your valuable time because even if
you are at home you've got plenty of
things you can be doing we appreciate
you spending some time with us we'll see
you back here again on wednesday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports